welcome back to the David Pakman show.
So Republican's did a nice little job of executing
a sort of temporary corporate media coup yesterday.
This is when, what by, I don't mean they took
over ownership of corporate media.
What I mean is they took over the attention
of corporate media when they pulled an obviously
unnecessary and just ridiculous political
stunt that was meant again to take over coverage
of corporate media for the day.
And they did it.
About 30 Republicans stormed a closed door
meeting yesterday as a protest of what they
said was being shut out of Trump's impeachment
inquiry.
What they said was a lack of transparency.
The specific meeting was one where Laura Cooper,
the deputy secretary of defense was going
to testify.
Republicans are saying none of this is legit.
Democrats are holding secret private meetings.
It's all bad.
Republicans reportedly storming in and taking
pictures in the meeting so that then the entire
thing was delayed.
It had to be swept by police for security
breaches and it ended up being a total childish
display of nonsense.
And in the end it served only to delay Lisa
Cooper's testimony by a few hours.
It didn't prevent it, but it did succeed at
getting Republicans some undeserved attention.
But here's the absurdity, and I wasn't even
going to cover this until I learned about
this.
These Republicans are saying the reason they
did this is there's a lack of transparency
that they're being shut out of the impeachment
process.
This is an inquiry that is being run by the
house intelligence oversight and foreign affairs
committees.
There are Republicans on those committees.
Republicans on those committees can ask questions
at every hearing.
They can review documents if they so choose.
The entire pretext or pretense of this protest
and barging in is completely bogus.
And Axios looked into the details.
13 so crazy.
13 of the Republicans who participated in
this protest are on the committees in question.
They can question witnesses, they can review
documents.
13 of the Republicans stormed a meeting in
protest over lack of inclusion and transparency,
despite the fact that they are already involved
themselves in the inquiry.
It was 100% iStent.
Corporate media, of course, fell for it, and
that's why I hesitated to cover it.
I got a lot of tweets saying, David, you've
gotta talk about this protest.
You've got to talk about Republican's barging
in.
You've got to cover the protest itself.
The reason I wasn't sure is because it was
such a patently bogus stunt, but in the end
I decided, you know, it's important to explain
first because lots of those Republicans have
access that they claim to be demanding that
it's a complete and total sham of a protest.
But also there's, you know, with Donald, everything
around Donald Trump seems to include not only
lies and distortions and personal motivations,
but witness tampering has been a big, big
part of everything that Donald Trump has done
around any investigation or attempt to just
exert oversight that is legally a, a possibility
for Democrats.
This could be argued to be a form of witness
tampering because this is okay.
The deputy secretary of defense ma, I'm guessing
that she's not going to be intimidated by
this, but when you're already directing people
to ignore subpoenas, when you already want
to suppress witnesses who could speak not
about the great things you've done, but about
the problematic things that you've done that
they've overheard, seen or witnessed, a great
way to indirectly tamper with witnesses and
to maybe influence them to opt out of participation
is to send a signal that their participation
is going to be disrupted.
Their participation is going to be difficult.
That also, by the way, how secure was the
facility if these Republicans were able to
just barge in in the middle and now there
is discussion among Democrats of we need better
physical security to protect ourselves from
Republicans who want to barge in with bogus
and ridiculous protests about things that
aren't actually problems.
Understand the insanity of that.
Understand the absurdity of in government
buildings, Democrats may need physical security
so that disgruntled Brown nosing sycophantic
Republicans don't interrupt the legal constitutionally
protected processes and investigations in
which they are participating.
It almost is beyond explanation, uh, with
the normal English language.